- Thank you so much for joining us
for a discussion on the
conflicts and synergies
between poverty alleviation
and climate change mitigation.
This is the fourth in a series,
the " Yale Development Dialogues
Economic Policy Lessons from History."
I'm Catherine Cheney, and
I'll be your moderator today.
So poverty reduction and
environmental protection
are often seen as conflicting goals.
But the climate crisis
is forcing many of us
to rethink economic growth.
So the question we'll be asking today
is what might that look like?
What are green pathways out of poverty?
And how might we redefine
international development
in a way that does not
present climate progress
and human progress as incompatible.
Joining us to discuss this topic,
I'm thrilled to welcome, Sunil Amrith,
the Renu and Anand Dhawan
Professor of History at Yale,
and current chair of the
South Asian Studies Council.
His research focuses on histories
of environment, migration,
and public health, across
South and Southeast Asia.
Julie Livingston is Silver Professor
of Social and Cultural
Analysis and History
at New York University,
and author of " Self-Devouring Growth:
a Planetary Parable as
Told from Southern Africa,"
which you'll hear more about.
Her work is at the
intersection of history,
anthropology and public health.
Rory Stewart is a Senior Fellow
at the Yale Jackson
Institute for Global Affairs
where he focuses on contemporary politics
in crisis and on international development
and intervention in fragile
and conflict affected states
and very relevant to today's conversation.
Stewart also served as
the UK Secretary of State
for International Development,
where he doubled the UK investment
in international climate and environment.
And faced some challenges in doing so
which I know I'm looking
forward to hearing more about.
And finally, Rohini Pande,
is the Henry J. Heinz II
Professor of Economics
and Director of the Economic
Growth Center at Yale.
Her work focuses on
testing innovative ways
to make the state more
accountable to it's citizens,
such as strengthening women's economic
and political opportunities,
ensuring that environmental regulations
reduce harmful emissions,
and providing citizens effective means
to voice their demands for state services.
So I'd love to open this
conversation with Sunil.
And Sunil you really championed this topic
as one we should feature in
the Yale Development Dialogue.
So I wonder if you can kind
of set the scene for us.
What does it look like and
what are some of the challenges
in terms of this perceived trade-off?
And can you take us
through some of the history
of environmental protection
and development being seen as a trade-off?
- Thank you Catherine.
And thanks everyone for joining us.
This was really brought
home to me just last month
when we had the collapse or
partial collapse of two dams
in Uttarakhand Northern India.
Many people were killed most
of them workers on the site,
and I was struck that
from more than a decade.
Environmentalist's in the courts,
have been warning,
that that sort of
infrastructural development
in such an ecologically
fragile region is reckless.
That a catastrophe like
this was almost inevitable.
And yet these projects plowed on.
And one of the first
responses to the disaster
by the Chief Minister of Uttarakhand,
was to very quickly point out,
that we shouldn't let what has happened
lead people to adopt an
anti-development narrative.
And that really gave me pause,
because I realized in a sense
how pervasive that view is.
The idea that environmental
consent is anti development.
And as a historian I'm very curious
and concerned with where that
pattern of thinking came from.
And I'd like to maybe just
give you two or three examples
'cause I think we need to
go back to the 1960s, 1970s
to really understand it.
The first example is Rachel
Carson and " Silent Spring."
Carson is rightly celebrated
I think as a scientific
hero of the 20th century.
We all owe a huge amount
to her courage and her intelligence.
But at the time and many in
the development community
felt like the rug had been
pulled from under them.
And the link of course was DDT.
Rachel Carson's " Silent Spring"
was one among a few factors
that led the US government
to withdraw it's massive funding
for the WHO's malaria eradication program
and to divert a lot of
that to population control.
Now the WH)'s program
was already in trouble
by the early 1960s.
There was a lot of evidence
of insecticide resistance,
but still there was a feeling
that this transformative
life saving technology
had been taken away.
I'll give you a second example
from about a decade later
early 1970s.
The Club of Rome's report,
"the Limits to Growth."
And in many ways that is a forerunner
of so many of the debates we're having now
about growth and the environment.
But one of the main concerns
of the Club of Rome report
was with population
growth in poor countries.
And immediately the response
from a lot of poor countries
was that the problem is
not population growth,
the problem is inequality
and over consumption.
And I think that one of the
most forceful statements
of that view
comes from India's Prime
Minister Indira Gandhi,
whose one of the few heads of state
to attend the first UN conference
on the global environment
in Stockholm in 1972.
And her speech there I
think still has quite a lot
of moral power to it.
Because the first thing she did
was to acknowledge environmental crisis.
But the second thing she did
was to say that it has to wait
for poverty reduction.
That poverty and her famous
line from that speech
is not poverty the greatest polluter.
And she added that the poorest countries
and perhaps the poorest
people within those countries
suffered from problems
that they were perhaps least
responsible at full causing.
Finally, I think through the 80s, and 90s,
you see a backlash against
animal conservation projects
that tended to treat local people
often very marginalized
people, indigenous people
as the enemy.
I think we need to
understand this history.
recognize the moral force
behind some of these arguments,
in order perhaps to move beyond them.
For the simple reason
that I think that today
and certainly in the medium term,
climate change and a whole range
of other environmental crises,
present perhaps the most
serious obstacle of all
to poverty reduction and
to large numbers of people
being able to live lives of dignity.
- Thank you Sunil
and I think that's a powerful articulation
for the importance of these conversations
needing to understand this history
in order to tackle these challenges.
And Julie, I see you nodding your head
it seems like you've come across
many of these dynamics in your research,
on the African continent
and specifically in Botswana
which I know is a focus of your book.
So can you tell us a little bit more
about, what I know you've
described as the consequences
of a growth at all costs model
and what lessons we might
learn from Botswana?
- Absolutely. Thank you Catherine.
You know Botswana for several decades
after it's independence from Great Britain
had one of the fastest growing
economies in the world.
It's had a really well-managed
development trajectory.
The standard of living has risen.
There are important
social welfare programs,
a functioning public health system,
participatory democracy, and yet,
climate change, is helping us realize
that even in a best case
development scenario
which most places cannot
realize, it's not sustainable.
There needs to be a
radically different thinking
about how this is going to work.
Botswana is currently
mining it's groundwater,
aspects of climate change
are contributing to desertification.
This is a place that
had been a carbon sink,
and yet nonetheless, is going
through a really drastic
kind of terraforming,
that threatens it's longterm wellbeing.
And I think, that raises
all kinds of questions.
First of all,
we have to recognize
that carbon is important
but it's not the only problem.
We have a whole set of
interlinked problems.
Toxicity and pollution,
the problem of waste,
loss of bio diversity, top soil erosion,
and they fit together into a web,
that is synergistic and
extremely threatening
particularly to people who
are already living in poverty.
When you start looking at it closely,
what you realize is that
you can't really separate
the problem into that of nation states
in the way that development
usually functions.
Botswana doesn't have
the ability to control
it's own climate.
It's not the major producer
of carbon in the world,
even though it is connected
in a global system
of consumption and trade,
that is ultimately reshaping it's climate.
Really most of the energy
of this is coming from the global North.
So where as development,
asks us to look at the problem of poverty
by looking closely at Southern countries.
I really think as many activists
in the South have long said
that the problem is in the North.
This is where the majority of
consumption and greenhouse gas
emission is coming from.
We are the people who set
the terms of global trade.
You know, if we were to
just close the tax havens
and re-localize wealth back to the South
where it is being generated
and extracted from,
already we would be doing something
that enables poverty reduction
without it being premised,
necessarily on a growth model.
So there are a number of
examples we could give
but I think development
unfortunately is constitutive
of the problem.
It's not something that's going
to be able to be moderated
by small technical fixes
or slight recalibration.
- Powerful points.
So when we talk about how
do we redefine development,
these aren't small changes,
this is an entire transformation
of the system that's needed.
So I wanna go to Rory now
and Julie we'll come back to you.
But Rory I know some of these dynamics
came into play when you were leading DFID
when you tried to make the case
for environmental conservation work,
for climate change action,
it was perceived as in conflict
with some of the development work.
So can you take us through
the challenges you faced
and how you ultimately
pushed through some of those?
- Well, thank you Catherine very much.
I think the, first thing is I came
to become a Secretary
of State, to run DFID
at a moment where the DFID budget was big.
It was about 0.7% of UK GDP.
So spending about 20
billion US dollars a year,
and approximately half of that
was being spent in Africa.
And it was a time when there
was an increasing consensus,
that we should try to tackle,
an environmental and climate
crisis alongside poverty.
So there were World Bank reports
and OECD reports suggesting
that if we didn't manage
to deal with problems
with climate environment,
we would end up with hundreds of millions
more people in poverty.
But when I actually began to try to shift,
the organization to focus
more on these issues,
I discovered there was an
enormous amount of resistance.
And some of that of course,
Sunil has demonstrated,
has a very long history.
So clearly what I was encountering
with civil servants were
memories of these debates
which had been going on
for many, many decades.
Part of it was as Sunil has
pointed to an instinctive
suspicion of projects
to do with non humans.
It's a very important thing
that generally speaking
when we talk about development,
we're talking about humans.
And people find it uncomfortable
being (audio glitches) talk about animals
or even about plants and habitats.
I think that's fascinating.
And that also goes simply
to the way that we measure things.
All the targets and different,
all the metrics were wrenched a round,
a hundred million girls
getting educational,
x hundred million people
being taken out of poverty.
The second thing was the way,
the economist measured things.
And a very strong sense,
from the development economists in DFID,
that by allocating money
to climate efficiently.
And this was not the most effective way
of maximizing the number of people
we were going, (audio glitches)
to take out of poverty.
Now, there are many questions
around this kinds of models.
Could we really take people out of poverty
in the mechanistic way that they imagined?
How did these models work?
Nevertheless, that was the way
in which they saw the world.
And this was sort of
suspicions that people had.
And I think the final thing,
and then I'll hand back to people.
It's important to
understand that institutions
developed program (audio glitches),
over 20, 30 years, they invest
in certain kinds of things
which are very difficult
for them to get out of.
So the Commonwealth
Development Corporation
would end up owning
a third of the electricity
generation of Tanzania.
And that would be carbon-based
electricity generation
difficult to extract from.
We just given another $4 billion
that come with development corporation
and it wanted to make
more lending on energy.
And most of the clients that it found
were carbon based energy crisis.
We were giving money
through development banks.
World Bank, African Development Bank,
which were funding projects
with heavy oil generation in Senegal.
And it was extremely
if I said, " No, we're stopping all this."
The general response for civil servants
was could we avoid stopping,
could we have a glide path?
Could we just sign off
on this heavy oil plant?
And maybe in three or four years time,
we can move out of this.
We need a longterm strategic position.
Some of that was genuine.
Some of that of course there's a hope
that the secretary of
state will be reshuffled,
before they have to actually shift the way
in which the program balance works.
I tend to supplement,
I mean there are many, many rich themes
that we can return to here,
but I think it's just, it was
a surprise to me to understand
that something that
seemed, so straightforward
and oddly was very popular
with the British public.
It was no real resistance,
from the British public
that international development money
could be used for climate environments
in fact it was one of the easiest ways
to defending the 0.7%.
Is to say to people
this is our contribution
to the fight on global climate change.
But the resistance from
within the organization,
was surprisingly strong.
Enough for me.
- Thank you Rory.
And you're right.
It's something that seems
so straight forward,
and yet actually implementing policies
that acknowledge the complexity
we're discussing today
is easier said than done.
And so that brings me to Rohini.
Rohini I'm curious whether
you can help us connect
this conversation, not only the topic
but the urgency of the topic.
To some of the conversations
happening right now
in development economics.
- Yeah, thanks Catherine.
And I'm very happy to be here.
I think, let me start by saying
what I'm not going to talk about,
which is, I think a very
common response right now
to think about this issue
is to invoke the idea
of de-growth.
Is to say that, we've had
enough of economic growth
we need to move towards
a world where we focus
on not growing more.
And I think what Rory said
really brings up the side
of that no matter what your objective is,
they choose, do you have the
policy levers to get there.
So I think just moving a conversation
from saying, growth is bad for the climate
let's move to de-growth,
is not going to be very helpful
because we don't actually
know how to do de-growth
any better necessarily than
how we know how to do growth
in the poorest parts of the world
that probably still need it.
So when we come to them
the issue of thinking about
how do we actually think
of policies for climate change,
I do think the issue
that comes up a lot of it
has to do with political economy.
And that both has to do with
if you think about who's
affected by climate change,
but also I think the
difference in doing policies
for mitigation versus
those for adaptation.
So going back to what
Rory was talking about
development agencies,
remember having a fast
(audio glitches) connection with someone
at one of the new large
investment banks in China,
who was describing that
they wanted to lend
for environmental purposes.
They wanted to lend
for ways of mitigation,
in a city, but it was very hard
to get all the stakeholders to agree.
So if you wanted to change for instance
how urban energy system worked,
you have to go and get five
different constituents on.
What was much easier
to do was after crisis,
have to go and say let's build a seawall,
or to go and say after say,
as soon as I said the
ultra con crisis happens
to go out and say we need to provide those
who've been rendered homeless, new homes.
And I think that's one
of the issues we face
is really if you want to address,
(audio glitches) climate carefully
and alongside therefore
affect economic development,
we need to be thinking
a lot about mitigation.
But it's hard to do
because the people who
are affected the most,
ex-ante they are also the
ones with the least bar.
And so in a society
with a lot of inequality
it's gonna be very hard
to persuade those who
are doing well today,
to look out for not themselves
but those were going to be
possibly rendered homeless
by climate change tomorrow.
So let me keep that as my
starting comments here.
That's right.
- Thank you, appreciate it.
And I do wanna go ahead
and welcome questions
from our audience.
I know we have a very engaged audience
and I'm always excited
to read your question.
So I have a few questions for the group,
but if you're joining us on Zoom,
please go ahead and submit
any questions you have
in the Q&A box.
But I wanna Zoom in on something
Rohini was just mentioning
in terms of inequality.
And, in line with our goal to
connect history and practice,
I'd actually love to start with you Sunil
and then hear from others.
What does history teach us
about the unequal impacts
of environmental degradation,
and how could this lens of inequality
help inform our conversation
around poverty alleviation
and climate change mitigation
and finding those synergies?
- I think the lens of
inequality may well be the key
to sort of taking this conversation
in a different direction.
Because I think we have
plenty of historical evidence
on any time scale you
want to think through
whether it's several hundred
years or the last 50 years,
suggesting that in fact
environmental threats,
environmental risks for
most heavily on the poorest
and most marginalized people.
They haven't been recognized as such
perhaps until recently.
And I mean I think that's one
of the historical trajectories
that I found interesting.
The fact that this was
not necessarily visible
in the heyday of, state
directed development
of 1960s, 1970s.
And yet I think that that is a place
where we can have a slightly
different kind of conversation,
not so much about whether we
are for growth or de-growth,
but how, addressing inequality
is just a constitutive part
as Julie was saying, of
the problem writ large
including the problem of climate change
but not limited to it.
I just also want to pick
up on what Julie was saying
about this is not just about carbon.
I think we do need to make sure
that we're having this conversation
in a way that recognizes
that our different
scales in different kinds
of environmental crisis
are supercharging existing
patterns of inequality.
- And on that point that
it's not just about carbon.
Julie I know your background
includes public health
and I wonder if you can speak a little bit
to when we talk about the
unequal impacts of climate change
this is not just in the
future, this is very much now.
So can you tell us a little bit more about
I know sometimes you described
this in terms of the upstream
and the downstream
and where development tends to be geared.
So one what do you think about inequality
as maybe a useful lens
or useful way to reframe the conversation.
And two, from your background
not just your research
but also your work in public health,
how do you connect that
with this conversation?
- Sure. I think that downstream,
there are, pressing an immediate concerns
like those that Rohini has been
gesturing toward absolutely.
You know when people need
to eat, they need to eat.
When their homes are flooded,
they need remediation.
But upstream, if we don't turn off the tap
that is creating this problem,
inequality grows and the need
for remediation just grows.
And that is becoming
evident in our day to day.
So when you think
upstream in public health
you realize that for example
in Africa where I work,
what until recently was
a predominantly rural
and agricultural continent
has been urbanizing rapidly, rapidly.
There are people who are getting
on tiny unseaworthy boats
in order to try to reach a place
where they will be able
to feed their families.
And way upstream at the back of that,
are a whole complicated
welter of relationships
and one of them are changes in land use
and land access patterns,
and the ongoing enclosure
of the commons that is pushing
people off of their land
and also the effects of climate change
that are making it so they
can no longer make a go of it
as a fishermen or as farmers, et cetera.
If we think in terms of the pandemic,
we know that the
evisceration of wild lands
is hemming in, wild species in ways
that are facilitating zoonosis
we've seen that with Ebola
now we see it again, with COVID.
So I do think of course that
mitigation at the coalface
needs to happen.
But I am a de-growth proponent
I don't see any other way.
I don't think we can keep
creating the problem,
and then trying to mitigate it.
There are people who fall
through the cracks continually
when that happens.
- I wanted to ask Rory a question.
Because Rory we heard
some of the challenges
you faced within DFID.
And I wonder as Julie just mentioned,
public awareness of some of
the very immediate problems
with the damage humans
are doing to the planet
public awareness is growing.
I mean COVID-19 and zoonotic
disease is one clear example
of how environmental destruction
is having very immediate human impacts.
Do you think it would be different
if you were leading,
DFID now as CDO,
if you were leading the UK's
aid portfolio right now,
could you make a different argument?
Could you build on that momentum
and can other leaders do
the same at this moment?
- I think you can.
But it's worth bearing in mind that,
it's still unfortunately
true that most polling
in most developed countries,
puts environments surprisingly low down
on versus priorities.
And the amount that they're
prepared to spend on it
is still very limited.
I discovered this for example
running to be mayor of London
when I was trying to emphasize
even which you would have thought
would really matter to
people like air quality,
let alone, things like planting trees.
I mean it turned out consistently,
that the campaign managers,
the putting advisors
would say Rory just
stop talking about that
people wanna talk about knife crime.
And they would show data,
credible amount of data
to show that people were not prepared
to spend even,
50 pounds a month,
to try to contribute
towards these associates.
So I think that's an important background.
On the specific question of
whether you can shift people
then develop budgets, yes you can.
But remember, that's
partly because in the UK
so long as we have the 0.7% target,
the voters subconsciously felt
okay that money is
already going to be spent
on this kind of stuff anyway.
So the question I'm not being asked
is not would I rather that
money was spent on healthcare
in Britain or right in Britain
or a school in Britain.
This money has got to be
spent abroad and therefore,
would I be happy,
that it was spent on
environment and climate work
or would I rather it was
spent on some other thing.
And framed like that,
it was very easy to make the argument
for farming to climate
work, with the public.
The problem though, just
to sort of cycle back
to some of the issue
that different people
have been talking about.
I think there's the big
problem which Julie has raised.
Which is that it's almost impossible
to get a political constituency
behind questioning growth itself,
in most developed countries.
Is very, very, very difficult.
Even the Green Party in Britain struggles
to actually make those kinds of arguments.
But I think the other thing
is that there is a real problem,
evaluating the quality
of environmental projects
on the ground and what their
impact is likely to be.
So for example if you were
doing flood management now,
it would be very tempting to
talk about natural solutions
to flood management.
So planting trees for example
to stop water movement.
But explaining clearly
that actually our modeling
on this is extremely complicated
that it matters a lot
if you're trying to
block flooding with trees
what season it is, whether
there leaves on the trees,
how old the trees are,
that actually that type
of management works better
when the trees are 20 years old
when they just being planted
and what all that means
for somebody downstream, who
might be flooded next year
and where the choice is being made
not to build a flood wall
but instead to plant some trees
that are gonna have some
impacts in 20 years time
there is a difficult
I think it's also true
when we make arguments
on organic farming.
Again many of them have a great enthusiasm
for organic farming but when
it actually comes to explaining
to a farmer in Zambia
what that's really gonna
mean in terms of the yield
from a hectare of crops,
things become much more complicated.
We don't really have good natural
capital measures in place.
And the final thing I wanted to say
is that again you know
this is quite granular
but it is very striking
how incredibly expensive,
a loss of current proposals
on habitat restoration.
I was the environment minister in Britain
before I was the international
development minister.
We were doing peatland
restoration projects.
Restoring peatland where
we would be spending
40 million pounds on reseeding,
a couple of thousand hectares of peatland
by dropping sphagnum
moss from helicopters.
They've just announced another
400 million pound project
to this sort of Britain.
And you can absolutely understand
I'm not gonna defend my defeat economists
why they might stick their
hands up and say what really,
is that the very best thing
that you can think to do with your money?
Can you really, demonstrate
the consequence of that?
So I suppose what I'm talking
about is bridging the gap
between similar absolutely correct point
that as a general statement,
the most marginalized poorest communities
suffer most from (audio glitches).
That needs to be linked
to the very specific question
of are you prepared to
spend 400 million pounds
on peatland restoration
by dropping sphagnum
moss from helicopters?
Or is it something else that
you wanna do with your money?
And we're surprisingly bad
at answering those questions.
- I wanna bring in some
questions from the audience here
and one of them has to do with growth.
And I feel like we might
have some differing opinions
among our panelists on
the way forward here
which I think it's always
interesting to engage
in some productive debate.
This question is posed to Julie,
but I'd love to hear Rohini
on this as well
and anyone else who wants to jump in.
But Sanjeev Kumar asks Julie,
what would it take to
convince the skeptics
of the de-growth idea
to change their minds?
Rory just noted that
that's very hard to do,
and I know you believe
that's the only way forward.
So what does it take to bring
others on board with you?
- Thanks and thanks for that question.
I actually think that
the public is onboard
with a number of de-growth
strategies already
like the basic income grant.
Something that has turned out
to be quite popular
here in the United States of all places,
which is definitely a de-growth strategy
and something that in the US
we were always told you can't have
and then after the pandemic,
it turned out suddenly
for a few months there, we
had a basic income grant.
I think the closing of tax havens,
is quite popular among the non Davos set.
Most of us are deeply
offended that some people pay
and many people really don't
particularly those with a lot of money
or corporations that
have places to hide it.
I think, having standards
against producing goods
that are meant to become
obsolete and disposable
within a year or two,
and be replaced, would be quite
popular among many people.
So I think that there are a
number of de-growth strategies
out there that are already popular,
and then you can look around the world
at different countries
that are taking on de-growth platforms
as part of their policymaking.
Whether it's the government
of Bolivia or Ecuador,
or whether it's New Zealand
which has unhitched it's
the drivers of it's policy,
from a growth metric.
So I think it's a debate and it's a debate
that many people are ready to have,
and the more that we unpack it
and start talking it through
and realize that de-growth
is not the same thing
it's just letting the economy crash out,
that in fact it's a very
planned and step wise move
into economic systems that are more fair,
more just, and that it will
not lead us off of precipice.
I think people are rational
and they're empirical
and they will get behind it.
- What do you think Rohini?
I know you've began your conversation,
mentioning de-growth
and actually that you
wouldn't be advocating for it
but as we unpack it,
how would you respond?
- Yeah. So I think it's
useful to distinguish
between de-growth within an economy
or within a local area.
And the question of what it means
in terms of global redistribution.
And I think this would go back
to a lot of the debates
that we've been seeing
in the aid world and development
is that as even (audio glitches)
are becoming more unequal,
it's harder very often,
to have a case both of
saying, let's not just have
say de-growth within the
US or in New Zealand,
but let's also send money
and resources to Botswana
or to other parts the world.
I think the combination
of the two is hard,
but if you really want
to affect climate change
we have to be thinking
about the global stage.
I mean I think that's one
of the big (audio glitches)
difference within say COVID
where people have recognized
that their health depends on others
but they still see it as
a very domestic issue.
I think everything for instance
we are seeing right now
on vaccine nationalism
is very much I want my
neighborhood vaccinated,
but it doesn't really ring true
for people to think that,
vaccination in Canada
is necessary for me to be protected.
So I think similarly, when
we talk about de-growth
and this is a thing
where Sunil started from,
you're going to get very
little constituents,
in favor of de-growth in say Sierra Leone
or in the poorest parts of India
where you still believe that
a lot of very poor people.
So if you have to take
de-growth seriously,
at a level that's going
to affect climate change
we have to ask how are
we going to accompany,
single individuals, or single cities,
and the rich not being
happy to (audio glitches)
quickly recognizing the
type of redistribution
that's going to be needed.
And I think that requires
a global coalition.
And that's why I think,
my push has been a lot more
let's talk about the policies
we need, to achieve those outcomes.
And maybe de-growth will be
part of it for the rich economy
but it's certainly not going
to be enough on it's own.
- Here is one more
question related to growth.
I see Rory wanted to come in.
So Rory maybe you can respond
to this question as well.
Jacob Rink, asking about this growth,
de-growth conversation.
Asked when we speak
about growth or de-growth
does it make sense to
differentiate between resource
and carbon intensive growth
and growth in services such
as education and health?
And I think,
we would agree to that
and I see nodding heads.
- Yes we are.
And I think it makes a lot of sense
to make all these distinctions.
I mean this is a very, very
difficult thing to resolve
this question of, how much
willingness there is behind this.
And Julie may well be vindicated.
I mean it may well be that
in 40 or 50 years time,
she'll turn out to be right.
It's very difficult to prove.
Generally people who are
campaigning for this kind of thing,
will tend to be on the optimistic side
and generally working politicians like me
will tend to be on the somewhat
cynical pessimistic side
about the ability to inspire populations
to do things that hit their pocketbooks.
And it's so one of the interesting things
about politics and changes,
these things are so unpredictable
and we clearly can feel this
in relation to civil rights,
we can feel this in relation
to many other changes
that we've seen in the 20th century.
So it may be that, this will shift.
I just say that it would be difficult
to find many working politicians
and major political parties
in Europe or the United States
that would really imagine
selling something as ambitious
as Julie is speaking about.
That's not to say that it won't happen,
but it's gonna be a hell of a fight,
if we're really gonna get
anywhere close to that.
We're talking about much,
much more incremental.
- Sorry about that Rory.
Sunil did I see that you wanted
to jump in on this question?
No. We have another question coming in
that I'd love to ask you all about.
So one of the themes that
came up in our conversation
is, who's responsible
to take action right?
And that developed countries,
it's often argued that the countries
that got us into this climate mess,
should be at the forefront
of getting us out of it.
So when it comes to what that looks like,
there is a question along the
lines of a, recent Biden...
Here let me find this question.
Where did it go?
There is a question around
the Biden administration
setting the social cost
of carbon to $51 a ton.
And this attendee anonymous asks,
this is still a significantly lower
than many other social
cost of carbon values.
What is the panel's view of the efficacy
of social cost of carbon
and mitigating risks to the
populations being discussed?
And maybe I'll broaden that question.
Any panelists who wanna comment
on the social cost of carbon specifically
interested to hear your views,
but more broadly I will
say, we should talk perhaps
about the US as a leader here,
we have a new administration,
new policies being rolled out for climate.
Might that be an opportunity
to harness some of the synergies
we're discussing right now
to change the conversation
around climate and development?
So since this question was posed
about the Biden administration
would love to hear any
thoughts on that opportunity.
- Let me comment very quickly
and then head of to us.
I mean I would've thought,
one thing is just to remind the US,
that there is an enormous
amount that they can do,
just to catch up even with,
offenders like the United Kingdom.
I mean the UK has had
the paragon of virtue
it's not New Zealand right?
But it's managed to significantly
reduce et cetera trustee consumption.
It's managed to move to a situation
where 40% of our generation at the moment
comes from renewables.
And it's done it relatively quickly
and relatively painlessly.
And the US hasn't even begun
to stretch it's muscles
to match the standard set
by major European countries.
- Thank you Rory.
- So I think...
Sorry, the reality is that the status quo
is extremely expensive.
A year ago like a 10th,
I'm making up this figure
of Australia was on fire.
Every year now, a huge part of California
which is a major driver
of our economy is on fire.
Look at what just happened in Texas.
And before that would happen in Louisiana
and what will happen
later in the next place,
in the next place,
this is just extremely
extraordinarily expensive.
But that money doesn't
disappear from the economy.
People make bank off of this.
People are making bank
off of this pandemic.
And if we don't start to
think about relationships
as relationships, but
instead as siloed events,
I think we are misapprehending
some of the drivers,
of our current predicament.
Including and perhaps especially
here in the United States.
- Thanks Julie and Rohini
I know you want us to jump in as well.
- Yeah, I just wanted to enter,
as you Julie's comments
are usually useful way
for me to jump in which is,
one way that economists respond
to this and perhaps the
social cost of carbon
epitomizes a test to believe
that if we accept this as the cost
we are going to accept a higher prices.
And so for instance thinking
about carbon pricing
are kind of cap and trade
systems, is very popular
the economist very often for saying
just let the markets enter and resolve it.
And I think as Julie pointed out
the Texas example is actually an example
where you were trying to
get the markets to work well
and they didn't.
And it's good to remember
why kind of even if you might
have a higher Instacart one
you don't want to rely just on markets.
So I think a couple of reasons for this.
So the first is pricing
is sometimes for consumers
much more sensitive in
some sectors than others.
So for instance gasoline,
politicians don't want to
raise the prices on gasoline.
So having kind of carbon taxes
that are going to translate
into the gasoline sector
is going to be much harder
than trying to introduce carbon pricing
and maybe electricity or someplace
but it's a much more if you want hidden.
And so I think pushing
on just one instrument
can often defeat the purpose
because you may just
want to play off the fact
that consumers care differently
about the marginal cost
of different goods.
And then the second thing
which I think comes from the Texas example
is I think what we saw is that yes
prices were able to adjust quite fast,
but the investor need to make
for these one off possible
frigid weather in Texas,
maybe seen as so rare
that the person who's building the pipe
is just not going to invest in that
because it's not worth their while.
They're not getting a huge return
when the energy price goes sky high.
So the energy provider gets it
but not the person who's
maintaining the pipes.
And so again I think this comes
to the issue of the system
that if you want to rely
on markets and pricing,
we have to realize that
there are a lot of players
we have to take along.
And that will often bring us
too much blunter regulation.
And so I think it's good
if you increase the social cost of carbon
but I think the danger is to then think
that the markets will take care of it.
I think that just doesn't happen.
- So we had a question
on social cost of carbon
which we addressed,
but we've so many great
questions coming in.
So keep them coming.
I wanna group together three questions,
that also relate to responses
while we're talking about responses.
And responses by different actors.
So we have one question
around the role of development
finance institutions.
So the question is, any thoughts
on current efforts by DFS and
international organizations
on engaging with Ifs,
insurers and asset managers,
to improve environment
related controls and policies,
exiting coal for instance?
So that's one question.
I'm gonna throw three
out and then we'll see
how we can talk around
these questions as a panel.
There is another question
around the role of the private sector.
How do you incentivize the private sector
to create green economy jobs,
that also alleviate poverty?
London stock exchange
has created a category
called the green economy mark
to attract issuers for example.
And now we move into the policy realm.
To what extent can environment
strategies be combined
into development policies,
to create new jobs that
would advance both goals
at the same time?
So related questions
around the role of development
finance institutions,
the private sector, and policies.
Combining environment
and development policy
something Rory touched on earlier
but all of this has to do
with how we respond and how
different sectors respond.
So any thoughts on any of those questions
I'll see which of our panelists
wants to jump in Rory.
- Well, let me firstly say,
that the overall theory
behind those questions
has to be right.
I mean, this far more money
sitting around in these
great financial centers
than there are in the development nations.
And if there were some
intelligent mechanism
for working out how you unlocked the money
that was in New York
or the city of London,
and directed it towards
the kind of projects
we want to do on a farm
climate or poverty alleviation,
that would be a very smart thing to do.
My role seems to be in the state,
than saying that in practice of course
this turns out to be
unbelievably difficult.
I mean, so I spent a lot of
time crushing around the city
of London trying to work
with the insurance industry,
trying to work with different
forms of investment firm,
trying to define green investment funds
and the amounts of money in the end
that we actually got,
available to be invested
was surprisingly limited.
Because there seems to be
fundamentally a problem
generally (audio glitches),
which is that these things
are not as profitable
as we want to pretend.
There is a reason,
why generally speaking
effectively public grant money,
is more likely, to be able to
go into some of these sectors
than credit capital.
And it's a lesson we learned
in a hundred different ways.
I mean, one of the most depressing things
about development in Africa,
is that it's very easy
to make a presentation
about the extraordinary
potential of Africa
the incredible human capital,
the incredible natural capital,
a great story about
how this is the future.
And you make those
presentations again and again
while being aware that British Airways
is shutting all the flights into Africa
the major hedge funds are
drawing out of Africa.
Barclay's Bank is getting rid
of all it's branches in Africa.
So there is a problem
that we keep returning to
which is the theory of
this, has to be right.
But nobody has yet managed
to crack this at scale.
- Thank you Rory.
Any other thoughts on those questions?
Otherwise we have plenty more coming in.
I'm thrilled with our engagement here.
I wanna to this question
from again Sanjeev Kumar here.
And I think it's very well put
and I wonder if this is
something Sunil might speak to.
Sanjeev asks my sense is that
the philosophical foundation
undergirding the work of
researchers and policy makers
is too narrow to empathize with the pain
the current course of
development and growth
is inflicting on people.
Do you think that we
need a deep re-evaluation
of the way we build
knowledge about the world?
- That is beautifully put.
And I think in fact sort of epitomizes
some of the what we're grappling with now.
Because in a sense, there
have long been multiple ways
of knowing the world,
fully capable of comprehending the pain
that some of the current parts
of development have inflicted
on people around the world.
Those are not the kinds of knowledge
that have tended to be
valued or influential
within the development sector,
or within a lot of policymaking.
So that is a gap that I think
has widened since the 1980s,
where there is a lot of
work by anthropologists
like James Ferguson
and others writing the
late 80s, early 90s.
He wrote a wonderful book in 1990
called the " Anti-Politics Machine"
about the sort of deep politicizing
thrust of a lot of development.
He's also worked in Southern
Africa like Julie at the time
and it doesn't seem to me that that debate
has really sort of intersected
with some of the conversations
that are being had within
the development sector
about metrics, about measuring success,
the kinds of points that
that Rory was making.
How does different measure success?
It may well be
anthropologists are involved
with the World Bank and are being employed
by some of the international
development agencies,
but it's not the same as to
say that some of those forms
of knowledge, have truly
sort of started to inform
or influence the way in which
we think about development.
And I mean I do like very much
the way that Sanjeev's use
of the word pain.
And I mean I think that is important.
These are very emotive topics.
One only needs to look
at the farmers protests
going on in India now
that sort of enormous
colossal scale to understand
that something has gone wrong.
In the sense that Punjab
was India's agricultural success story,
since the green revolution
and clearly that masks so much inequality
and so much that is now manifesting itself
in really a major political movement.
- And Sunil you mentioned
the farmer's protest.
That brings me to a question
from Camille Hassan,
who asks about the role of labor.
So I think we've talked a lot about,
from a policy level, private sector,
more top down in some of the framing
in terms of actions to be taken.
Now I'd love to talk a little bit more
about in the grassroots
advocacy bottom up, if you will
and not that I love that framing
but here is the question
from Kamil Hassan.
I'd like to perhaps push onto
the urgency of this question
the way Sunil began.
What is the position of labor,
in the contemporary moment?
And Kamil asks about the US for example
in the midst of a struggle
to raise the minimum wage,
but how do we engage with labor
with regards to the
conversation on growth?
So any thoughts on that labor
and then perhaps more broadly
just advocacy and demand
from people most effected
by where we go from here?
I see Julie might want to
jump in on this go ahead.
- Yeah I will say that, in
Botswana where I do my research
where you've had this really
spectacular economic growth,
high unemployment has
remained in tractable.
There is something happening
in our global economy
which is the evisceration in
the slow disappearance of labor
in many ways.
And we see that manifest
in the kind of political reconfiguration
that you still lean on labor,
as being the political entry point
for certain sectors of society.
And that's being, heavily,
heavily impinged on.
I'm glad that the person
writing the question
was pointing to the US
where we see that around the minimum wage.
And we see it around tensions
over union organizing
and essential workers right now.
I think that can be generalized globally.
And I do think that it is one of the ways
that the basic income grant
is just incredibly important.
Because many people in
this world have no choice
but to sell their labor at a price value,
that is absolutely unacceptable,
or to turn themselves
essentially into a debt,
in order to be able to transit somewhere,
to be able to be employed.
And that can't be the solution to poverty
or the environment.
- I wanna throw in, Rory did
you wanna jump in on that?
- If I can very quickly
just to very strongly agree with Julie.
I mean one of the most
heartbreaking things
in many many Sub-Saharan
African countries in particular,
is the unemployment rates.
I mean around the edges of Dar es Salaam
you've got unemployment rates
amongst young people of about 85%.
And the population
of course is growing unbelievably quickly.
So that by 2050 it's projected
that one in 10 children born in the world
will be born in Nigeria.
But the hope which is that
you could combine capital
from the developed world with the labor
from rapidly growing places like Africa
just hasn't happened.
And indeed changes in technology,
robotics, AI et cetera,
suggest it may not happen.
And so, it's actually very miserable.
I mean I get very sad
when I get about Botswana.
Visiting communities which
as Julie says theoretically
moving into an upper middle income status
but where everybody is basically,
is struggling to feel at ease.
- Well, I would say that I think Botswana
is doing pretty well for the
majority of the population.
But that said, these are economies
that are based around extraction.
And that is sort of the
elephant in the room
that we haven't really talked about.
They're extractive
and that's meant to provide the employment
and then the purchase,
in a global marketplace that
doesn't localize production,
you know I don't know.
I feel like the WTO is
somehow get another elephant
in this room, that maybe we haven't.
- That's a really interesting point
and it relates to one more question
I wanna bring in from the
audience as we start to wrap up.
Because it's forward-looking.
So this is from and I hope I'm
saying your name correctly,
Morrison Bluhm, who asks
how can the global North
transform the conversation
from carbon emissions
to inequality, as well as the
global North's own history
of over-consumption?
So I don't know how optimistic
we are that that can happen
but what would that look like?
And how might it happen?
Any thoughts from our panelists?
- So I think one,
I mean just link this
back to the last question
on thinking about labor movements.
So (audio glitches) we think progress
and we think about these
kind of broad discussions
about the green new deal
or the linking of things
like, the minimum wage
to saying that we want to
think about growth differently.
That maybe one way forward.
My concern does remain
that these tend to be quite
domestic conversations.
And so I think that another
place to think about
which I feel we started
too one of the last one
but not really is, how climate change
and also the lack of kind of good jobs
in the developing world
is, underlying a lot
of what we see on the migration trends.
So if you think a lot of what's happening
on the kind of the cold, severe up,
or from Central America to the US,
has its deeper roots in
sort of climate change
combined with, people first
go to the urban centers
in this country there aren't a
lot of jobs (audio glitches).
I mean that's perhaps
also way that the world
is going to get into LinkedIn.
Maybe at some point we'll
stop having the nasty reaction
that we can just keep people out
and actually start
dealing a little bit more
with the root causes.
But I think labor is going to be critical
to how we link these conversations
across rich and poor countries.
- Agreed. So we have just
five minutes left here
and I wanna quickly hear from each of you
if there's anything we didn't
get to in this conversation.
I'll throw in one question I had
that I'd love any thoughts on
but we'll open it up to see
what you might wanna add.
So I think one thing we
weren't able to get into
as much as I would like is measurement.
So we talked, we had a bit
of a debate around growth,
de-growth, rethinking growth,
but that has to do with
what metrics we use
and I do think there is growing consensus
that economic growth
is not the best metric
to capture poverty
reduction, biodiversity,
the wellbeing of people and the planet
and how interconnected that is.
So if this is a moment for a reset,
how might we change the way we measure?
So that's a question from me
but perhaps panelists have
something else they'd like to say
with just a minute each we'll go around.
I'll actually start with
Rohini if that's all right.
And maybe we can end with Sunil,
where we began.
So Rohini let's start with you.
Final thoughts, and perhaps
it has to do with measurement
or anything else you'd like to note.
- Yeah so I'll start the measurement
actually a different measurement
than the one you talked about
but one about measuring the
effects of climate policy.
So I still think a case that
a lot of the discussions
on how climate change policy will happen
is being undertaken by lawyers.
So a lot of these conversations
we know happen among kind of in,
it could be COVID-26 coming up
otherwise it will be a lot of lawyers
talking about work done
or what are the
responsibilities of countries.
Without thinking about implementation
of how you would measure it.
And I think we repeatedly
see a lot of the failures
of international climate change policy,
coming from not thinking
about how we measure them.
I think a classic example
for instances is offsets.
Offsets have become very popular
as a way of thinking about how you would,
do your little bit for climate change.
But how do we know what we're offsetting?
Would that action even have happened?
I mean that goes to the
heart of what I think,
economists measure all the time,
which is what was the count of factory,
what was going to happen
without the offset.
And I think if that room
didn't just have lawyers
and people sort of thinking
about what is acceptable
to the private sector,
but actually thought about
measurement and impacts,
maybe on this policy we would
also make a bit more progress.
So that's from me.
- Thanks Rohini.
Rory we'll go to you next.
- So for me on measurement,
I think it's really important
to look at a measurement
and natural capital
which is very central
to the policy debates
certainly in the UK.
But actually increasing the elsewhere
in terms of trying to work
out how you attach a value
to carbon, climate, biodiversity,
and people's interactions
with natural landscapes.
It is unbelievably difficult,
to get any sort of agreement around it.
Because small differences in how much
value you attribute for example
to measure or an aesthetic appreciation
can completely transform
the value you ascribe
to a particular landscape.
It's very, very difficult
to explain to the public,
it's something that is
in a dangerous situation
because it's something
where, we have a strong
emotional and idealistic
attachment to the idea
of natural capital measurement,
and that therefore
suppressing some very good
and critical questions about
how these models operate
and whether they're really effective ways
of allocating resources.
Getting that right is gonna
be a very, very important part
of determining particularly
how governments
choose to spend their money.
How treasuries assess investments
in these kinds of things
both domestically and internationally.
- And Julie thoughts from
you on how we measure
or any other closing thoughts you have.
Oh you're on mute.
There you go.
- You think after a year of this
I haven't learned about that?
I think moving away from
GDP as the measurement
is really important.
As a public health
person I know for example
the GDP is underneath all
kinds of health indicators
and how they're modeled.
So for example when GDP goes up
the maternal mortality rate goes down,
whether or not there are
women dying in labor.
So I think it's a blunt
measurement that needs to go away.
And I'm a huge proponent of the work
of the development economist Kate Raworth.
R-A-W-O-R-T-H, and I recommend
you all read her book,
" Doughnut economics" which
puts forward a different model
of measurement.
- Thank you Julie.
I love when I come out of
conversations with action items.
So I appreciate that.
And we'll close with Sunil.
Sunil I think this has been
a fantastic conversation.
I appreciate you being the
one to suggest we have it.
What are your closing thoughts
or any calls to action for this group?
- My closing thoughts
is not about measurement
it's that we haven't said
anything about China.
And I think if we are going
to think about the future
of growth and de-growth,
we probably need to engage
with what those might mean
in the context of the
belt and road initiative
in the context of China's
ambitions across Eurasia
and indeed into Africa.
And so I would just
sort of end with a call
to really take a global
perspective on this,
perhaps even moving
between the global North
and the global South in
the traditional towns
we think about development.
- Thank you Sunil.
Perhaps the starting
point for a future edition
of the Yale Development Dialogues.
Well I wanna make sure we end on time.
Thank you all so much
for the great questions,
and we'll make sure to get back to those
we didn't have time to answer.
Thank you to our panelists
and stay tuned for upcoming additions
of the Yale Development Dialogues
where I think as we've all
just seen the value of here
we bring historians and
practitioners together
to discuss some of these
very complicated issues
and the way forward.
Thank you all.